football coach betching who teaches the
game like a dance a combination of hip
twisting knee lifting and shinga or
Brazilian swing
add to that a touch of deception and
you're ready to steal the ball from your
opponent
said than done
but young Neymar followed the rules of
his first instructor to the T
is
Neymar was very smart in school and on
the field
he's a great imitator he picked the best
tricks from the greatest players and
make them his own
um
first spotted Neymar when the future
start was five years old
former football player named our senior
had taken his son to watch him play
I saw this child climb up and down the
stands with an unusual agility he had
quick reflexes body control and the
makings of a star
I asked to meet his parents and started
training him in indoor football until he
was old enough to move on
but she will help Neymar join the youth
leagues of the Santos team Santos is one
of Brazil's biggest teams with a
glorious past it has been the breeding
ground of many stars notably Pele and it
was here that Neymar made his
professional debut at 17 and where he
reached International Fame
while playing for Santos Neymar averaged
a goal every other match and helped the
club win the prestigious libertadores
the teams first since the 60s during
pele's time
from there he went on to play for
Barcelona until 2017 when he signed a
record-breaking 260 million dollar
transfer deal with
most Brazilians consider Neymar a native
from Santos the largest port in Latin
America but he was born into a simple
and humble family near the city of
moshidas cruzis
people here ask me how I recall helping
deliver Neymar when 400 babies are born
in this hospital every month I remember
because his father played for the local
team at the time and was well known in
Mulkey
off the field he's had his fair share of
bad press a tax evasion Scandal and a
rape accusation which courts dismissed
after considering Neymar a victim of an
intended scam at the time Brazilian
president James bolsonaro stood by the
player
I believe Neymar is innocent
in return Neymar endorsed bolsonaro's
failed bid for a second term in an
extremely divisive election in October
prompting criticisms from Brazilian fans
who supported his adversary
president-elect Louisiana Silva
what he thought instead of sitting on
the fence the fence is for cowards while
the Brazilian squad is in Qatar aiming
for an unprecedented six World Cup title
back in Santos bacino is preparing a new
generation of Neymar's
Monica Santos Brazil Al Jazeera